right you gotta
I'm assuming
Conway's on the
the pain version okay because I know
Conway's got that pain you know that
Carly on the B side you know Conway is
one of one of my favorite uh rappers in
the world and you know Benny liked the
puppet he found yeah he's like Benny's
like the pop star Griselda if any like
the popular [ __ ] yeah Conway is like the
pain you know what I'm saying it came
perfect bro I told I told me I said no I
need both of them on there the fact you
got me on the ASAP Conway on the B-side
[ __ ] crazy nah nah uh shout out to both
of them like uh how how in tune have you
been with what griselda's doing with
both with both of those guys always been
the tune from the beginning I'm a fan of
Benny Conway gone yeah I'm a fan of
Griselda period you know what I'm saying
so
Benny that's my brother me and Benny
been knowing each other since 2014.
great we don't even know that I say that
all the time people don't even know go
back and look me and Benny got songs
from 2014. I'd have been a buffalo [ __ ]
with him in this Hood yeah man I've been
to Buffalo with those guys I'm saying so
Conway always been a fan of it and I'm
just telling Mick like man I gotta do
what you feel me like I'm in the traffic
when I get in traffic I'm playing that
[ __ ] bro I'm playing Benny [ __ ] I'm
playing Conway [ __ ] like you know what
I'm saying but it was certain times you
know you go through some [ __ ] mentally
you only hit one song yeah you feel me
like
um
can't wait when he when he came to God
the album oh my intro let's play a song
every day it's a [ __ ] classic I used
to listen to that song the intro that's
the one with Dej Loaf right no God oh
yeah Dave loaf is track two yeah and
that guy used to get in the car and
listen to that song every day as soon as
I got in the car it's a classic album
[ __ ] I know that's what I'm telling you
I listen to that [ __ ] every single day
when I got in the car bro so good
yeah some of the bars on that album just
some of the [ __ ] he was saying man [ __ ]
different it's different Conway's in my
opinion like when it comes to just like
lines that you're just like like I just
feel it in my mouth different
like Tupac had that like Conway's got
that where you're just like [ __ ] like I
got goosebumps because I felt you on
that [ __ ] no [ __ ] ah man that [ __ ]
different bro I love that [ __ ] he's
different for real and I told him that I
give him his fly I'm gonna get any real
[ __ ] flowers I got two no I thought it
was dope you had both of them on it
obviously Gunners on the project uh it's
looking like he's probably crying out
yeah free gun or free slime man free my
twin and for I can't wait